do you remember the pain oh all of it
yeah I was awake through every moment
you have a video which is haunting it's
January 1st at 8 42 in the morning 13
minutes away
eight ribs broken in 14 places right
knee right ankle broken left leg tibia
broken the left ankle broken right
clavicle broken right shoulder broken
face-eyed socket a jaw the mandible
broken lung collapsed pierced from the
rib bone your liver everything like
what's my body look like am I just going
to be like a spine in a in a brain like
a science experiment I heard that you
had in sign language you said to your
family I'm sorry
sorry
do you dream of doing those studs again
I've lost a lot of Flesh and bone in
this experience but I've been refueled
and refilled with love and titanium